whoa
whoa whoa
whoa
whoa
[Music]
oh my ears and whiskers my pocket
watches stopped uh excuse me sir do you
have the time please tell me that's your
pet rabbit that's mr w robert to you
ma'am there's a talking rabbit that
nobody can see but us you're adorable
don't talk to me like i i i like that i
like that very much
whoa i asked why are you here it's a
mystery
i love mysteries my name is alice this
isn't wonderland it's middle school
let's see we started seeing strange
messages whoa
so we're dealing with a ghostwriter whoa
it's rolling out the white carpet
whoa
[Music]
what is happening
donna told me you're solving the mystery
for a ghost who's releasing characters
from books
and you believed her
[Music]
she's a clone of siobhan
they're identical
together we can do anything look i can
give you a whole speech about how ash is
wrong or you could save us the time and
just trust me because i get higher
grades than he does she did not just say
that
[Music]
whoa
we went into the book
we became book characters
styling
excuse me monster lady we come in peace
we're your friends see
i got this
i don't got this
whoa
what is that
i don't think these cowboys are from the
old west
what are you kids staring at
nothing
okay
[Music]
whoa
is that the mona lisa
did that rat just drop that car prepare
for a quantum timeline
dinosaurs well
i actually thought moving here would be
boring
who knew i'd be having conversations
with a talking rabbit
time traveling with the pirate and his
pet rash
and it all started in this bookstore
well a clue from ghostwriter
i did not see the end coming i couldn't
believe it whoa whoa whoa spoiler alert
you sure have a colorful imagination
[Music]
what are you doing
uh we're practicing our miming you never
know when cirque du soleil will be
hiring